maps from all over the world can be
found at the click of a button but
sometimes places that look blank are
actually full of life
[Music]
this is primosh
and this is isaac
primosh and his company spatial
collective work with community
organizers like isaac to map unmapped
communities
despite the popular belief the world has
not been mapped yet
unmapped communities are literally not
found on maps
important things like roads schools and
hospitals are missing
when communities are unmapped
governments can easily overlook them
this means that they miss out on vital
resources that they should have access
to
informal settlements are usually not
connected to the former grids such as
water or sanitation or even electricity
so the maps make communities legible or
visible to the outside world
the process begins with members of the
community gathering information on foot
we use various mapping tools including
gps and mobile phones to collect data
these data points are then sent to the
team at spatial collective they plot
them and fill in the map
when citizens have information about
what they're missing they have the power
to advocate for what they deserve
madara is the second largest slum in
kenya
it's an area where there's a lot of
issues
lack of proper sanitation there's
insecurity so we've collected a lot of
data we've mapped all the hospitals
mapped all the schools
mapping empowers
me to make sure that we bring services
to our people
a picture tells a thousand words and
with map that is more than true
it can attract more investment more
interest it can help in many different
ways once you know what's there
[Music]
you